first I've got some breaking news for
you and no one better to bring it to you
then mark Kleiman hey mark what can you
tell us yeah okay this is more
devastating news for Britain's car
industry if confirmed now I understand
that Honda the Japanese car maker is
drawing up plans to permanently close
its manufacturing site in Swindon with
the potential loss of as many as three
and a half thousand jobs now I'm told
that these plans are due to be announced
tomorrow morning and the company is
refusing to comment this afternoon so
these plans are still unconfirmed but if
they are confirmed in the coming hours
it will be really bitter news for
Britain's automotive sector which is
already reeling from a series of
negative announcements in recent weeks
including Nissan's decision not to build
his x-trail SUV in Sunderland and
thousands of job cuts at both Jaguar
Land Rover and Ford now Honda has had a
presence at Swindon since the 1980s it
manufactures well over a hundred
thousand civic cars at Swindon each year
and Swindon is its only factory
currently in the European Union now one
thing that people will inevitably
speculate on but we can't say for
certain at the moment is how much of
this decision is related to Britain's
impending departure from the EU and the
fact that companies still have very
little clarity about the terms of future
trade with Europe with brexit a
potential No Deal brexit less than six
weeks away but nevertheless this
announcement if it comes will be seen
through that prism and it probably won't
be the last such announcement from a
major manufacturer elsewhere in
manufacturing the likes of airbus have
warned about the potential impact of an
Odile brexit as well and to put this
into context for Honda Honda had said as
recently as last September Kay that it
was committed to manufacturing in
Swindon my understanding is that if this
announcement is confirmed tomorrow
the company will say that it's going to
close the Swindon plant in 2022 so still
three years or so away but nevertheless
three and a half thousand workers at
Swindon facing an uncertain future as
well as thousands more jobs in the
automotive sector supply chain which
rely on the production from that Swindon
plant so we'll wait for further news
from Honda and I'll bring it to you as
soon as I have it just to clarify you
four people treating our way all the
time of course obviously mark three and
a half thousand jobs we're talking about
and likely to be formally announced what
tomorrow that's right three and a half
thousand people work at Honda's Swindon
manufacturing plant there are other jobs
as I say in the supply chain which are
dependent on that I do understand that
Honda will retain its European
operational headquarters at Bracknell in
Berkshire as well as its Formula One
teams presence in the UK but
nevertheless in terms of the car
manufacturing sector if confirmed the
closure of Honda's Swindon plant will be
a genuinely savage blow